Oh Lady Gaga is back and she's singing
about stupid love
[Music]
that's right not only did mother monster
release her highly anticipated new
single stupid love on Friday but she
also dropped the music video and it is
fire
[Music]
the entire video was shot on an iPhone
11 Pro and features some kind of Mad Max
futuristic battle in the desert with
fierce choreography obviously god I love
a dance battle
[Music]
et chatted with Tom Feeny one of the
dancers featured in the video and he
revealed they shot the video in January
a few hours outside of LA and said
working with Gaga was like a quote
master class she would direct before and
after each take and then transform in
front of the camera she spoke with
hearts with intention I gotta say while
I love an emotional ballad Gaga really
missed this side of Gaga the quirky
poppy Gaga who wears outfits that make
us say what's the living hell I was
expecting don't you derive in like an
egg or you know something on the head
did he tone it down with my egg rental
you know it wasn't available
welcome back girl it's been three years
since the singer dropped a solo single
on us and I am here for it Thank You
Lady Gaga recently opened up about the
new song and her upcoming album on new
music daily with Zane Lowe on Apple
music I know everyone in the world has
different relationships but love but
guess what I'm pretty sure that when we
all decided to be vulnerable it's really
scary I think it's very scary for a lot
of people I really want to do them with
this song to come out and I'd love for
it to collapse as many of those walls as
possible and people would be saying I
want and maybe just maybe Gaga's new man
is giving her something to sing about I
think it's always wonderful to shout
love from the rooftop the 33 year old
was spotted out with tech CEO Michael
Polanski on New Year's Eve then they
were snapped kissing over Super Bowl
weekend in Miami
quick background on Michael he went to
Harvard and co-founded / runs Facebook
co-founder Sean Parker's philanthropy
foundations
not too shabby gaga but anyway back to
the music
[Music]
Gaga announced earlier this week that
she would release stupid love and it's
music video just weeks after the song
was leaked online the single is off her
highly anticipated untitled sixth studio
album which will be her first since
Joanne in 2016 I want people to dance
and feel happy you know someone asked me
the other day what my goal was with this
album it actually sounds ridiculous when
I say that loud when I go I said I would
like to put out music that a big chunk
of the world will hear and it will
become a part of their daily lives and
make them happy every single day
mission accomplished lady mission
accomplished
of course you can count on et to bring
you all the latest on Gaga's romance and
her new music so make sure to keep it
locked right here until next time I'm
Hallie Stevens I'll see you soon